Hi there. I'd like to tell you about graduate opportunities at Portswego. We are a cyber
security company. We're based in the northwest of England, not far from Manchester. We make
software and we create knowledge aimed at enabling the world to secure the web. We're
a global leader in our industry. We have over 50,000 customers in 150 countries. Pretty
much every company you've heard of is using our products to help make their website secure.
What's our team like? We're a diverse group of people. Software engineers, writers, researchers,
graphic designers, customer champions, a long list. What we have in common is that everyone
is exceptionally good at what they do and passionate about it. We provide a fantastic learning
environment, especially for graduates. You'll be working alongside some world-class people
in your chosen field. We find that graduates who join us learn and develop way faster than
those at other companies. What are we looking for? In our graduates, we look for very strong
academics. That means top A-level grades and degree from a good university. We don't fixate
on degree subjects. Our software engineers don't have to study computer science. Some of them
studied maths, physics, chemistry, many other subjects. What we want to see is strong aptitude
in your chosen area and ability to learn. As a technology company, we would love to see
more women working in the tech industry. We are missing out on all the value that you could
bring. So if you're a young woman and you've considered a career in tech, but you aren't
sure, go for it. Our work is highly varied. We have so much fun. We work together very collaboratively.
Our people don't fit the normal stereotype you might have of socially awkward nerds. Anyway,
do check out our career pages. If you think Portswigger will be a good fit for you, we would love
to hear from you. Thank you very much.